from jenna speaking of catholicism
i'm a catholic woman in her mid-20s i
met my boyfriend three years ago when i
was struggling with my faith
due to this we did not wait until
marriage to sleep together but
especially in the past year or so
i've been struggling with guilt and
wanting to stop until we're married how
do i tell my boyfriend
he respects your opinion so what are
some arguments as to why this would be a
good decision for ourselves and future
marriage thanks
i think this is a great idea and i you
know it's weird because a lot of
people beat themselves up over this they
say okay well i did one thing
in the past and then i've now changed my
mind about that thing but i feel like
i've still got to do that thing which i
now think is wrong
no you don't you've changed your mind
now change your behavior
it's a little bit easier to change your
mind than to change your behavior
sometimes
but surely your behavior should follow
from that changed
mind what are some good arguments for
this
well a good argument from tradition is
simply that
this has developed when our society had
a sane
sense of social relations and it
developed presumably for a reason
and you don't you actually don't need to
boil that down to
an explicit rationalist ideological
summation of why it works the very fact
that it has worked for so long and led
to flourishing cultures
is in itself actually a pretty good
argument
uh why is it better to wait until
marriage well it's better to wait until
marriage even though in this culture
virtually nobody has done that
especially among millennials or gen z
but when we realize it is better why is
it better well because
it represents a commitment it represents
a giving holy of yourselves
to the other person presumably if you've
been sleeping together before marriage
probably you're using contraception i
would imagine that in itself
also part of catholic teaching is uh
withholding withholding a very important
piece of yourself
from your spouse and so in a way it
represents you and your spouse using
each other
merely for pleasure not to to
give yourself holy to someone nor
macdonald the comedian has a great bit
on sex i forget which album
of this of his this is but go back and
check it out he walks in he goes into
this nightclub and goes okay so
you know i was thinking the other day
that uh sex is a filthy
shameful thing that is obviously only
meant for procreation
and you know gets this big shock and
surprise from the whole audience
but the thing is he's sort of right you
know and he goes through all the reasons
the reasons why so that's a more comedic
way of thinking about why this is
and another reason that it might behoove
you
to stop now and then wait until you get
married which by the way good friends of
mine have done
friends who were definitely
getting down to business before they had
a reversion to the faith
and then they have paused it before
their marriage one of the reasons is
that the anticipation will make the
marriage itself one of the most
significant events of your life
more special you know the kind of
catholic idea of the world is first the
fast
then the feast the idea is we live in
time and space and so it is
important discipline for us to fast
sometimes to deprive ourselves of
certain things to discipline ourselves a
little bit
and then on feast days to
gratify some some more of those longings
and
through this process we come to a fuller
understanding not just of our bodies but
of our spiritual selves as well
and the the tough line on
other religious ideas and certainly on
secularism is instead of first the fast
then the feast
you have first the feast then the
hangover and that that's the culture
that we're living in right now
and that's just not the best way to live
for human flourishing so
i hope somewhere in there you get a good
argument to uh
to convince your boyfriend because i'm
telling you if you take a little break
for a while
it'll be that much better when you start
[Music]
again
you